В Україні мене звали Онофрієнко.
Моя родина тоді свідомо не хотіла носити єврейське прізвище Вайсбанд - через недоліки, яке воно там означало.
Мій дідусь, який пережив Голокост, усе своє життя читав газети, напружено стежив за настроями в країні,
а 1993 року він сказав: "Нам треба їхати. Негайно".
Я боялася незнайомої країни. Але мій батько тоді втішав мене.
Він обійняв мене і сказав: "Знаєш, У Німеччині, приміром, нікого не цікавить, що ми - євреї. Там ми можемо бути просто людьми".
Ми переїхали до Німеччини, ми знову взяли прізвище Вайсбанд…
Сьогодні на молитву в синагогу я йду через контроль безпеки. Я уважно читаю газети і напружено стежу за настроями в країні…
Марині Вайсбанд 33 роки. Вона народилася в єврейській родині в Києві.
У 1994 році, коли їй було шість років, разом з батьками переїхала до Німеччини.
У Міжнародний день памяті жертв Голокосту її запросили  виголосити промову на традиційну церемонію в Бундестазі,
адже вона не лише уособлює молоде покоління євреїв у Німеччині, а й є їхнім голосом.
Я знаю, що частина моєї родини була в евакуації. Я знаю, як моя прабабуся рятувала своїх дітей.
Я думаю, що Голокост для всіх, хто цей час прожив, є травмою, і цю травму батьки передають своїм дітям.
Марина Вайсбанд - доволі впізнавана в Німеччині людина.
Ще будучи студенткою, вона стала відомою політикинею.
У 2011 році її обрали співголовою "Партії піратів". Вона очолювала партію на піку її популярності.
Пірати вірили, що інтернет - істинне благо для демократії.
Вони виступали, зокрема, за реформу авторських прав і свободу поширення інформації, але проти стеження за онлайнкористувачами.
Не тільки на демонстраціях, а й на так званих криптовечірках, на яких вони навчали шифрування електронних листів.
Інтернет дає нам революційні можливості для розвитку демократії й обміну думками.
Марина Вайсбанд не тільки поєднувала навчання в університеті і роботу в партії,
але ще й видала книгу під назвою "Ми називаємо це політикою" про "електронну демократію".
За кілька тижнів до появи видання у продажу вона виставила свій текст в інтернет - для всіх безкоштовно. Як справжня піратка!
У лютому 2014 року, в розпал Євромайдану, Марина Вайсбанд вирушила на батьківщину в Україну.
Вона висвітлювала події на Майдані в німецьких ЗМІ,
а також ділилася з українцями своїм досвідом про те, як робити "політику без політиків".
Я повинна сказати чесно, мене задовбали після всього цього. Путінські тролі поламали мені твіттер. Я пів року не могла заглядати на твіттер.
Я перестала говорити публічно про Україну.
Я, звичайно, далі спостерігаю, по-іншому не можу. Були прекрасні моменти, наприклад, що зробили в Києві з поліцією.
З іншого боку, коли я подивилася, як відбуваються реформи юридичні, - мало надії.
Марина Вайсбанд, яка покладала великі надії на інтернет, сьогодні не приховує свого розчарування. У 2015 році вона покинула "Партію піратів".
Я думаю, що ми тоді були наївними і говорили, що якщо є інтернет, то автоматично все буде демократично.
Інтернет сам по собі не робить нас кращими або гіршими, вільними або менш вільними.
Інтернет підсилює ті сили, які вже є. Він просто як мегафон.
Марина Вайсбанд вступила в партію Зелених і вирішила повністю присвятити себе сфері освіти.
Вона вже шість років веде проєкт, мета якого - навчити школярів жити в демократії. При цьому вона не забуває і про Україну.
Коли я тут зроблю хороший проєкт у сфері освіти, тоді я хочу перенести це в міжнародні мережі, працювати з українськими дітьми.
Тому що я думаю, що якщо в Україні є якась надія політику виправити, то це діти.
Марина Вайсбанд у дитинстві дуже хворіла. Лікарі в Києві не могли їй допомогти. Саме тому її мати вирішила емігрувати на Захід.
Лікарі в Німеччині врятували дівчинку. За це Марина Вайсбанд вдячна країні, де здобула успіх і визнання.
Однак вона не збирається замовчувати і проблеми, які є в Німеччині.
Я отримую багато листів з погрозами мене вбити, зґвалтувати тощо.
Я думаю, що неможливо бути євреєм і антифашистом в Німеччині без того, щоб такі речі отримувати. Це не більшість населення.
Але чого я хочу від більшості населення, - не просто щоб вони не брали участі в такому, а щоб вони не мовчали, коли вони це бачать.
Саме це послання стало головним у виступі Марини Вайсбанд в Бундестазі в День пам'яті жертв Голокосту.